hey guys this is andrew from
trainingsensors.com let me quickly
introduce myself i've been
working as a professional trader for the
past six years in hong kong
and i've decided guys very recently to
create my youtube channel
because i want to show you guys how
portrait is actually working
and i want to show you all the different
tools and techniques that i use to make
money on the markets
and most importantly guys i want to show
you how to use it yourself
so in this video i want to show you how
to apply idiot wave principle to amc
let's get into it
[Music]
so this is amc chart we are on the
28th of march sunday in hong kong and
let's analyze
what happened at the end of the week for
amc and let's try to apply
all this price action to the illiad wave
principle
so the first thing you can see guys is
that
here we have the first wave then here we
have abc
second wave so very quickly moves up
developing
five waves one two three four five and
moves down
develop in three waves corrective move
abc
zigzag or flat elliot wave principle is
actually this little game that consists
of trying to use all the rules of
illegal wave
theory and apply them to the counting
that you're trying to make on the price
action
for those who are interested to know
more about the theory just click on the
link in the description of this video
and you're going to receive
a free training that i just finished
you're going to receive it right away
guys
where i explain everything about idiot
wave principle about what i've read in
the book and i show you guys how to use
it on
the market so here what we are trying to
do
is to do accounting on the price action
that is coming here
and once again moves up develop in five
ways
move them in three wave abc let's do it
so one two
three four five let me put this
in yellow so once again guys when you
have new information you need to use it
i was trying to make a different
counting before this moves down
happen right now i have no other choice
than making this counting like this
and this is uh respecting all the
illegal theory rules
so right now we are having zigzag you
know because we always have zigzags or
flat corrections
so guys i'm a bit worried here because
the only way i can do a zigzag is if i
do something like this
so i'm not saying that this is what is
happening
like 100 sure but this is the most
likely scenario all right
you can always do something like this
all right so maybe there is going to be
a bit of a weird zigzag
here and that this is not happening and
that we're having a one two three four
five
but once again this is not my preferred
scenario my preferred scenario is that
we correct maybe a bit
more before bouncing back so where are
our support level we
have a beautiful support level at 7.50
so this is the worst case scenario all
right guys
so if this happens don't panic this is a
very beautiful level to actually
buy more amc shares and if you don't see
this happening but you see the abc is
finished and that
we got something like this which is
possible as well guys
then we expect one two three four five
taking place here
whatever happens all right whatever
happens this
is still gonna be a one two right
i don't know if it's one two here one to
here but then we're gonna have
three four and five all right so guys
very interesting to see what is gonna
happen this week
ultimately we're gonna go higher i don't
see any other
possible counting here let's focus on
especially the second wave we want the
second wave to be finished
for a second wave like this to be
finished we need to see some
consolidation
and some higher highs and higher lows
this is what we're looking for
we are looking for a magnitude that is
shifting positive right now here the
magdy
on the forest time frame is still
negative but we can see that we have
some green bars appearing here
so it's not very clear but the momentum
is slightly starting to shift
so anyway i expect for the worst case
750 as a level that we're going to hit
but
not long as you're not going to have a
lot of time if you want to do something
at this level do it quickly
and then we're going to bounce back so
this is my view let's see how this plays
out
so that's it for me i hope you guys
enjoyed this video and if you did
please don't forget to click on the sub
like and bell button
so you're going to be the first to know
when i upload anything new and stay
close to show
i'll see you guys